Oh, dogs!
A best friend that always has your back.
In fact, studies have shown that men are three times...
...more likely to get a girl's phone number if they have a dog by their side.
And do you ever feel like your dog just gets you?
It turns out that humans and dogs both respond to emotional sounds.
When your dog hears you crying or laughing,...
...the response in their brain is similar to that of a human's.
You've probably heard of drug-sniffing dogs,...
...but did you know that dogs can sense seizures,...
...detect low blood sugar and can sniff out cancer?
In one study, dogs were able to identify 30 of 33 cases of prostate cancer...
...by smelling participants' urine.
It's believed that dogs' highly sophisticated sense of smell...
...can detect variation and the presence of volatile organic compounds.
Their sense of smell is 10,000 to 10,000,000 times more sensitive than humans...
...depending on the breed.
On top of it all, humans really do love dogs!
A recent study found that dogs activate the same hormonal response...
...that triggers us to love and care for our own babies.
Accompany that with studies showing decreased stress and anxiety,...
...and it's clear why they have become such an important part of our lives.
They truly are woman and man's best friend.